Continuing in Kitab al-وجيز in the book
of purification.
In the second chapter, which is the
chapter
of
the various types of filth. When we use
the word filth, we're speaking about
an-najasah. The word najis
and
najasah
and najis, these are terms which come
and originate in the Quran and Sunnah.
And as we mentioned before, these
terms
have many
Islamic laws built and based upon them.
One of the principles with respect to an
najasa, for instance,
is that
kullu najasatin
haram.
[Arabic recitation]
For instance, one of the principles that
the fuqaha
mention and and use and cite as evidence
for their conclusions
and that they take into consideration
when arriving at their conclusions
is that every filth is by nature haram.
However, not every haram is
filthy.
So, every filth,
okay, whatever we whatever the Quran and
Sunnah has
dictated, has identified as being
filthy, as being najis, specifically
with this word, najis, or rijis, or
riks, all three of these words have a
similar meaning in the Quran and Sunnah.
Anything that is deemed to be najis,
it is by default haram. Its consumption
is haram.
Its use is haram, etc.
However, not everything that is haram
is necessarily najis.
Not everything that is haram is
necessarily filthy and has the rulings
of filth.
So, we see that
these
things which are deemed to be najis,
it's very important for us to identify
them
and to work out what is najis, what is
not najis,
in order us to have a strong foundation
to base
the remainder of this
chapter on and this book, the book of
purification.
[Silence]
He
takes an excerpt here
quote from Al-Rawdah an-Nadiyah
a well-known book of fiqh
that defines for us what exactly the
word najis means. What does the word
najis
mean?
He says, "Najis and as we're translating
it, we're translating it as filthy or
filth, right?
We don't mean this in the
general sense. We don't mean that filthy
meaning unclean. Najis here is a ruling
and we are going to quantify
the list of that which is najis. It is a
finite list.
It is a list with
certain things on it
and that list is then complete and
nothing else is added to that list.
But linguistically, what does the word
najis mean? And in the general sense,
what is meant by najis in the language
of the Quran and Sunnah? He says
najis with najasa
is anything that is considered to be
disgusting
and by the measure
of general human decency.
When a person, those who are
you know,
general humanity, not any of the
outliers, not any of the extremes
of humanity.
But, general
humanity will consider these things to
be
disgusting,
revolting.
He says, "And the
general bulk of humanity and
specifically the Arabs and in their
culture at the time of revelation,
they would take pains to
purify themselves from this
najasa, from this thing that is
considered filthy. They would purify and
protect their clothing from it.
And this Then, he gives an example such
as
feces or urine.
If we were to look at all cultures ever
in human history,
do does every single culture view urine
to be filthy? No.
However, the bulk and majority
of moderate human culture,
those who
are upon
more or less the fitra, they do view
this to be something that is impure,
something that is filthy. Filthy.
He then gives us a principle, which is
very important. And this principle is
what he is going to base the list of an
najasat on.
He says, "Well, also feel as she had and
he better with the heart."
He says, "And the default
position, the disposition of everything,
everything in this world,
because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says,
khalaqa lakum ma fil ardhi jami'an.
Allah describes this earth,
and he says,
"He has created
for us everything that is in the earth.
He has created for us everything that is
in the earth.
Okay?
So, the default position of everything
that is in the earth
is that it is pure,
and that it is permissible.
It is pure,
and it is permissible.
The only thing which is not pure or not
permissible
is whatever the Quran and Sunnah have
specifically
outlined as being impure, specifically
outlined as being impermissible.
The general rule,
the general default of everything and
its ruling and its
nature is that it is pure,
and that it is permissible.
A a a tahur
[Arabic recitation]
He says, "Faman za'ama najasata aynin
ma, fa'alayhi bid dalil."
He says, "And so, based on that,
anyone who were to come and claim
anything,
or if anything is claimed to be
contrary to that description
anything of this earth is claimed
to be impure
claimed to be impermissible
claimed to be filthy
then there must be an evidence from the
Quran
and or the Sunnah
There must be a clear evidence from the
Quran or the Sunnah outlining that it is
in fact impermissible or that it is in
fact impure.
He says
[Silence]
He then mentions a very important point
and of course this is also a
continuation of the excerpt from
Al-Rawdah an-Nadiyah.
He mentions a very important point and
that is that
people
are not guilty for that which they do
unless considered guilty
by Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
And when we say by for that which they
do
meaning that which they do, that which
they consume of this world. Because
again, remember the general description
that Allah gives us is
He created for you.
For you
obviously this term for you
speaking to humanity
right? Because this is a continuation of
ya ayyuhannas
in Surat al-Baqarah. Oh people, to all
people, humankind and jinnkind, those
whom the Prophet Muhammad was sent to,
sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
And so created for you, it is
inconceivable
for it to be simultaneously for us, yet
impermissible at the same time. Or
considered to be for us
but impure simultaneously. No.
The description of for you meaning that
it is pure and it is permissible.
Now there are exceptions to that general
rule.
Those exceptions have to be clear-cut
from the Quran and Sunnah.
And not everything that has been posited
by the scholars of Islam or by some
scholars of Islam as being impure or
being impermissible is necessarily
correct because evidence
is of varying degrees
of strength and weakness. Some evidence
is very strong.
Some evidence is very weak. Some
evidence only appears to be evidence,
etc.
And so
anything
that is exempted from this very very
important principle
then it has to have something clear from
the Quran and from the Sunnah.
That Allah says he has created
everything for you that is around you
that which you consume, that which you
wear, that which you do, that which you
right?
This is not in worship. This is speaking
about in general life, human existence
in this world. Everything is permissible
except
just the first story that Allah
tells us right after this verse.
He goes on to tell us
[Silence]
The first story given to us not a few
verses later
is Allah saying, "Oh Adam,
live you and your spouse in this garden
and eat from anything that you desire.
Enjoy all of it, any part of it,
but do not come close to these
tree this tree. Either a type of tree or
a particular tree.
And so that is exactly the situation
here on this earth.
Everything is for us. Enjoy everything
except certain things which have been
outlined that are the exception to
the rule.
Right? So everything is not only
permissible in its original nature, but
it is also
it is also pure
in its
default nature. So then he begins the
list of eight things which are
considered to be najis. Eight things
which are outlined by the Quran and
Sunnah to be filthy, which we'll discuss
[Arabic recitation]